Waren Sie schon mal in Peru? Podcast UV ist der Besten, Podcast auf der ganzen Welt. Eine hinreissende Weise blöd. So blöd, das gibt's ganz selten. das Podcasts für Podcastprojektes als Intro von unserem lieben Hörer Josef. Josef, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei bist, dass du uns die Tür aufgemacht hast. Vielen Dank. Wir sind natürlich hier wieder heute zusammen, mir gegenüber natürlich der gebrochene Mensch Stefan Tietze. Ich bin gebrochen, wurde aber wieder geflickt, bin aber noch nicht wieder zusammengewachsen, aber zumindest liege ich geflickt jetzt da und gegenüber von mir sitzt der, dem es immer irgendwie gleich geht, nie besonders gut, nie besonders schlecht. Klingt aufregend. Hast nicht wahnsinnig viel Energie, an manchen Tagen mehr als an anderen, immer so bei 60 Prozent, mein lieber Freund, 60 Prozent, Florentin. Danke, vielen, vielen Dank. Aber das muss man sich sagen, deine 60 Prozent sind mehr als die meisten 100 Prozent. Aber das ist eine Dankeschön. Aber ich habe auch noch Platz nach oben. Ja, natürlich.
Selbstverständlich.
Ich dachte eigentlich, du hattest ja letzte Woche deine Schlüsselbein-OP auch und ich dachte, jetzt kommt hier Stefan Tietze hier rein, irgendwie mit Krücken gebrochen, mit so einem Tropf, mit so einem kleinen Rollgestell, wo der Tropf dranhängt. Und jetzt kommt Stefan hier rein, flickflack machend, ist hier Spritzfidel.
Sag mal, die moderne Medizin, was kann sie nicht? Und das ist auch das Thema für die heutige Folge. Ja, nee, dann würde ich mir wünschen, den Titel umzudrehen. Wobei, uns käme das ja entgegen, mit unserem Unwissen, unserer Unwissenheit käme ja entgegen, wenn man den Titel formuliert, das ist ja auch wichtig für Vorlesungen und so, wie heissen die Titel, moderne Medizin, was kann sie nicht, finde ich nicht so schlecht. Da können wir mehr sagen, da haben wir mehr beizutragen. Wie hast du es geschafft, Schlüsselbeinbruch und jetzt nur mit ein paar Globuli bist du wieder auf den Beinen gekommen, wie ist das passiert? Das Impulsreferat Schlüsselbeinbruch und was dann hier vorschlagen. Ich, ja, folgendes. Im Spannungsfeld zwischen Schmerz und Chance, das Schlüsselbein. Folie eins, müsst ihr euch jetzt vorstellen, seht ihr jetzt nicht, habe ich hier für Florentin, ist ein großes Schlüssel-Emoji und ein großes Bein-Emoji. Und ein großes Bruch-Emoji, diese Explosion. Seht ihr gerade hier, das wäre die erste Folie für einen kleinen Lacher. Wird die gesamte Präsentation nur mit Emojis geführt oder wirst du irgendwann Abstand nehmen? Ja, ab Folie vier nehme ich Abstand. Wirst du dich davon distanzieren? Ab Folge vier nehme ich nach Jahren Abstand davon. Also ich möchte sagen, das empfehle ich keinem Schlüsselbeinbruch. Wir haben ja rumgespottet, noch vor wenigen Folgen, ist ja fast ironisch, kann man sagen, dass mir das Schlüsselbein gebrochen ist.
Letzte Folge für alle, die es nicht genau wissen, was passiert ist, hör doch die letzte Folge.
Genau, ich bin bei einem, ja, beim tragischen Unfall, wo ich Menschen das Leben gerettet habe, bin ich von einer Lok angefahren worden. Du hast dich vor die Lok geworfen.
Die habe ich dann zum Stehen gebracht auch, dabei ist zu Schaden gekommen, Beweisstück A, mein Schlüsselbein.
Sehr konzentriert. Und das Schlüsselbein für alle, die es nicht wissen, weil ich wusste auch nicht, es ist hier irgendwo so in der Schulter drin. Das haben deine Recherchen ergeben, deine einwöchige Recherche ergeben. Eine vierzehnsekündige Recherche hat das ergeben. Ja, das ist der Knochen, der quasi von deiner Schulter, die äusserste Ecke, hin zu deinem Unterhals geht. Das heisst, wenn das jetzt nicht geklappt hätte, dein Schlüsselbein zu reparieren, dann hätte man deine Schulter direkt an deinen Hals quasi andocken müssen, weil dieser Abstandhalter nicht da ist. Was sehr witzig ausgesehen hätte. Als Feedback kann ich das auch mal sagen. Cool, ja, vielen Dank für das Feedback. Wenn ihr Feedback habt, gerne an zentrale-at-podcast-ufo.org. Also man muss sagen, es ist der häufigste Bruch bei Erwachsenen. Viele fragen euch, was ist der häufigste Bruch von Kindern? Dafür ist aber jetzt nicht der Ort, weder der Ort noch die Zeit. Ja, meine Frage wäre, was ist der seltenste Bruch von Erwachsenen? Wo sagt der Arzt wirklich, das kann brechen? Das ist noch nie gebrochen. Das kann brechen? What?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen, also der häufigste Bruch ist ein bisschen lame, muss in den meisten Fällen aber nicht operiert werden. Ich glaube, 80 Prozent kommen ohne Operation aus, weil es wieder zusammenwächst. Der wächst aber nicht so schön zusammen. Da hat man häufig am Erwachsenen so einen Knubbel da oben. Es ist auch leider Gottes einfach ein sehr sichtbarer Knochen, weil da nur wenig Haut drüber ist. Das heisst, die meisten Leute, wenn ihr euch quasi die bisschen die Schulter nach vorne beugt und den Kopf ein bisschen zurück macht und von Spiegel stellt, oberkörperfrei, seht ihr eure Schlüsselbeine. Ich sehe da jetzt eine Riesenplatte, weil da wurde jetzt, ich wurde operiert vor zwei Tagen, drei Tagen und ja, Vollnarkose, der ganze Schüssel, 90 Minuten lang wurde ich mit, wurde eine grosse Platte jetzt drauf, wurde es aufgeschnitten einmal. Ich habe mir vorher den großen Fehler gemacht und das Operationsvideo angeschaut. Und irgendwer hat überlegt, wir gehen Knochen um wie mit einer Wand. Wir machen da eine Platte drauf, dann nehmen wir einen Bleistift, machen so ein kleines X in die Löcher, dann holen wir einen Bohrer raus. Also einen billigen Akkubohrer von Aldi. Tatsächlich wird da so eine Platte draufgelegt, die wird dann fixiert, dann holt man einen Bohrer, macht in die Löcher Bohrlöcher rein und dann kommen einfach mehr oder weniger handelsübliche Schrauben. Ja. Kommen dann da rein. Bei mir sind sechs Stück. Der Körper ist ein Haus, sag ich immer. Der Körper ist ein Haus und wann fangt ihr an, es zu bauen? Oder so. Ja. Jedenfalls. Hast du jetzt eine coole Narbe? Ja, die ist sehr extrem, so locker, so 25 cm, 20 cm lang, von meiner Schulter hin zu, ist schon geil, vor allem, weil die nicht so ist wie andere Narben, sondern so piratenmässig geflickt. Das heißt, du hast wirklich so Stich, ihr könnt mal Schlüsselbein-OP eingeben, ihr seht dann ein Bild von Sebastian Schweinsteiger. Okay. Er ist Sebastian Schweinsteiger. Der macht auch für alles Werbung, oder? Der hat dann mal einen grossen Werbekampf an. Nee, der hat erstmal dann Oberkörperfrei rumgelaufen und hat einfach eine sehr coole Narbe. Und die habe ich jetzt, glaube ich, auch, aber ist noch ein Pflaster drauf, deswegen kann ich es nicht sehen, ein hypoallergenes Pflaster. Hättest du dir nicht gewünscht, eine Narbe zu haben, die man mehr sieht? Oder willst du jetzt mehr oberkörperfrei umlaufen?
Ich bin jetzt mehr oberkörperfrei zu sehen.
Okay, verstehe.
Genau, und dann wurde die, dann habe ich danach noch ein Röntgenbild machen müssen, ob dann ja alles gut aussieht und die Platte und die Schrauben, alles funktioniert hat.
Und dann habe ich zum ersten Mal verstanden, wie hochauflösend Röntgenbilder eigentlich sind. Weil ich weiß nicht, ob du, stell dir mal ein Röntgenbild vor. Aber es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr grossartig, wo ist jetzt Tiefe, wo ist jetzt was Festes. Du siehst Knochen, da sind teilweise aber irgendwie Organe davor oder sowas oder der Darm, dann sieht man dahinter nicht den Knochen so richtig. Das ist alles so ein bisschen so vages Bild, ein vages Schwarz-Weiss-Bild. Ist es nicht, denn meine Schrauben waren mehr oder weniger fotorealistisch, da war halt wieder dieses vages Skelett und dann richtig so Böller-Schrauben, die sah man wie eins zu eins. Es ist wirklich wie ein Schwarz-Weiss-Bild von einer Schube, was ich so mit dem Handy machen will. Man war einfach so Deckschrauben zu sehen. Sehr, sehr klar und umrissstark, also wahnsinnig. Es ist komisch, dass man das Organische nicht so gut sieht, wofür es eigentlich gemacht ist, aber dann das Metallische richtig gut. Gut gesehen, ja. Sehr gut. Ja, jetzt sieht man diese Platte, die kann ich dann nach einem Jahr irgendwie rausnehmen und so. Echt, aber willst du dir rausnehmen? Alle sagen, nimm die lieber raus. Die Stirn.
Es gibt keine einzige Stimme,
die sagt, lass sie drin.
Nee, es gab in meinem ganzen Krankenhausbesuch nicht eine Stimme,
die gesagt hat, lass sie drin.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Es gibt kein
Thema auf der Welt, wo sich alle
hundertprozentig einig sind. Es gibt
immer ein, zwei, die sagen,
nee, nee, dann ist es noch stärker.
Und wenn du das nächste Mal fällst, hier, pass auf, dann kannst du hier schön gegen die Wand rennen den ganzen Tag, weil die Platte macht dich stark. Ja, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch ist ein Mensch, der Mensch, sagen, nee, nee, dann ist es noch stärker. Und wenn du das nächste Mal fällst, hier, pass auf, dann kannst du hier schön gegen die Wand rennen den ganzen Tag, weil die Platte macht dich stark.
Der Mensch ist sowieso schwach. Wir vom Cyborg-Verein, Brunst, Bodel, wir sagen eh, der Mensch soll mehr und mehr zu Metall werden.
Es gibt doch Interessengruppen, die Metall im Körper wollen.
Es gibt Interessengruppe Metall, IG Metall, Interessengruppe Metall, aber die stecken gerade in so einen Urheberrechtsstreit. Die kriegen ständig Post zugeschickt. Deswegen kriegen die nicht so viel hin, unter uns gesagt. Aber du bist jetzt halt Mensch, halt Maschine. Ich bin 97 Prozent Mensch und drei Prozent Maschine. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt am Flughafen durch den Metalldetektor gehst, dann wirst du rausgewunken.
Ich habe einen Implantatschein, den muss ich vorzeigen.
Aber ist der befristet?
Nee, den habe ich mal nie, wie lange habe ich jetzt einen Implantatschein.
Das heißt, du könntest, sobald das Metall wieder raus ist und deine Waffe rein, dass du sagst, wenn sie die Platte rausnehmen, können sie da so eine Uzi.
Ja, aber wir sehen, dass es kein Implantat ist, was Sie da haben, sondern man sieht durch ihr weisse Shirt, dass da eine Waffe ist. Ja, aber dafür habe ich den Schein. Ich habe einen Implantatschein. Wir glauben aber, dass Sie da drüber noch eine Waffe haben. So, passen Sie mal auf. Ja, ich habe hier eine Waffe. Ich bin bereit, durch meinen eigenen Körper durchzuschießen, nur um sie zu treffen. Okay, kommen Sie durch, kommen Sie durch, kommen Sie durch. Also nicht schlecht, das heißt, du hast jetzt, du bist jetzt für Drogenschmuggler ein Stück interessanter geworden. Dein Wert ist gestiegen, weil du hast jetzt die Möglichkeit, einfacher durch die Sicherheit zu kommen als davor. Ja, ich glaube schon, aber mein Wert ist gestiegen. Das heißt, und alle ... I will 9-11 the shit out of this world. Das heißt, du bist jetzt tatsächlich für kriminelle Elemente in dieser Welt ein gutes Ziel geworden. Nee, ich glaube, dass sich das ausgleicht von meiner sonst eher ungefährlichen Art, bin ich jetzt bei 50-50. Ich glaube, ich bin jetzt so interessant wie alle anderen Menschen für die kriminelle Unterwelt. Du brauchst einen Bonus, um auf Null zu kommen und jetzt, okay. Ich glaube, ich brauchte einen Bonus, um auf null zu kommen, jetzt bin ich da. Also ich hatte auf jeden Fall eine Megazeit im Krankenhaus, ich musste eine Nacht dableiben, wurde operiert und alles war cool da, ich habe auch wieder gedacht, eigentlich ist es für mich psychisch der beruhigendste Ort im Krankenhaus. Ja. Ich hatte so eine gute Zeit in diesem Krankenhaus, klar, ich weiß, jetzt möchte ich nicht viele Mails bekommen, again, an zentrale at podcast-ufo.biz, dass es natürlich tragischere Unfälle gibt und so.
Aber es war ja wirklich, es war ja für mich wie so ein Planspiel Krankenhaus, weil ich ja von Anfang an war klar, ich bin nur ein, zwei Nächte da und so deswegen habe ich ja diese Outside-Perspective gehabt, um einfach einen sehr angenehmen Fall,
um im Krankenhaus zu liegen,
um aber trotzdem die Krankenhausexperience komplett durchzumachen.
Und ich fand es fantastisch.
Allein dieses Ankreuz, was man zu essen haben will,
diese geregelten Zeiten, um 18.30 Uhr geht das Licht aus.
Es ist genau meins.
Also dann war es auch wunderschön im elften Stock.
Und hattest du ein Einzelzimmer?
Nein, ein Zweibettzimmer.
Okay.
Mit dem lieben Markus, wir haben die ganze Zeit gelabert und sind dann beide gemeinsam eingeschlafen. Markus, schläfst du schon? Ja, ich wollte eigentlich jetzt schlafen. Du, ich wollte nur sagen, dass es mich ... Wir haben schon gute Nachgesagt. Ja, ich wollte nur sagen, dass es mich echt freut, dass wir beide auf einem Zimmer sind. Ja, sonst kommt wieder der Arzt rein. Ja, finde ich auch. Ich finde es voll cool. Hast du... Was sind deine grössten Träume? Ich möchte mal so cool sein, dass ich mal von einem Drogenschmuggler angesprochen hatte, ob ich nicht was schmuggeln möchte. Ja, ich auch, will ich auch gerne. Hey, hey, hey, ich wollte nur sagen … Was denn, ich wollte nur sagen … Wir haben keinen Delay, es ist kein Telefonat, wo der eine irgendwie in Island ist oder so. Hey, hey, was denn, ich wollte nur sagen, dass ich, dass ich es cool finde, dass du hier auf meinem Zimmer bist.
Okay, finde ich auch cool.
Oh, gute Nacht, ne? Ja, gute Nacht.
Kann man jetzt eine dritte Ebene eigentlich geben? Gute Besserung. Wenn man mal redet, normal
sagt man jemandem, gute Nacht, gute Nacht, dann ist
Stille, bei Sleep Sleepover. Dann ist
der gesellschaftliche Vertrag
Stille. Jetzt kann noch ein Gespräch anbegonnen werden, aber leiser. Nochmal so, weißt du?
Ja, stimmt. Wenn man aber auf dieser Ebene sagt, hey, gute Nacht, gute Nacht, gute Nacht. Ja.
Hey, hey, Markus, diese Ebenen finde ich auch anstrengend.
Ja, Markus, ich wollte nur noch eines dazu sagen.
Gute Besserung. Danke, ja. Danke, gute Nacht. Jetzt, gute Nacht. Hallo. Marco. So kann das die ganze Nacht weitergehen. Ist die Stelle endlich, kommt ein Arzt rein. Ja, dann kam, dann habe ich sehr gut geschlafen eigentlich, Schmerzmittel waren auch toll.
Auf dem Rücken?
Oder wie, also du meintest ja, du hast Schlafpositionsprobleme. Hat sich das einigermaßen ergeben oder?
Das ging dann, die Schmerzmittel haben geholfen und keine Probleme, war alles gut. Dann bin ich da gerügt. Und dann kam mitten in der Nacht ein Arzt rein, nämlich der Arzt, der mich am Anfang in der Notaufnahme schon begrüsst hat, entgegengenommen hat, aufgenommen hat in dem Krankenhaus. Der kam dann nachts, da war dann der zuständige Arzt für die Station in der Nacht. Und der kam rein und hat gesagt, voller Lautstärke, und ich habe schon geschlafen, dass er nach dem Besuch recherchiert hat, wer ich bin. Weil es um den Auftritt ging in München, weil ich gesagt habe, ich kann nicht nach München fahren. Und er hat gefragt, bist du da für das Oktoberfest? Und ich habe gesagt, nee, nee, so ein Auftritt und so. Und dann wollte er genau wissen, um was es sich da handelt. Mein Breakdance-Auftritt, ja. Und hat dann danach recherchiert, meinen Namen gegoogelt und wollte mir dann nachts sagen, dass er das cool fand, was ich gemacht habe.
Hat sich dann aber, ich fand,
einen persönlichen bönen Zeitpunkt ausgesucht.
Ich stand dann nachts
drin und ich war völlig verballert.
Aber es war sehr lustig.
Er stand dann mitten im Raum und dann
Stefan,
ich wollte nur sagen,
dass ich das echt gut finde, was du machst mit dem Podcast. Hey, könnt ihr beide ein bisschen leise sagen? Okay, sagen wir mal. Aber es war ein sehr cooler Aufenthalt, ich muss sagen, ich hätte da tolle Menschen um mich herum, kompetente Menschen um mich herum, junge, erschreckend junge Menschen um mich herum, also alle Ärzte waren so gefühlt wie die Serie The Good Doctor. Ja. So ganz kleine Menschen im Sinne von jung. Noch ganz ... Kleine Jungs haben sich um mich gekümmert. Ja, so ein Kinderkrankenhaus. Aber es war ja auch die Uniklinik in Köln. Also ich kann nicht nur empfehlen. Hatte großen Spaß, alle Ärzte waren super funny, ich hätte eine gute Zeit. Und jetzt gibt es ja das Sprichwort, was dich umringt, macht dich stärker, hast du das Gefühl, du bist stärker? Aber das habe ich noch nie verstanden, dieses Sprichwort. Das ist falsch, ne? Das Wied dabei sein ist alles einfach Unsinn, glaube ich. Nee, ist nicht alles, das ist das wenigste, was es gibt. Das ist das wenigste, was es gibt, das ist die Hemmschwelle, um dabei zu sein. Dabeisein ist alles ist fast nichts. Dabeisein ist fast nichts. Dabeisein ist fast gar, dabei sein ist, du hast noch nichts geleistet, du bist dabei. Genau. So sollte das umformuliert werden. Und was sich nicht tötet, hat dich vielleicht schwer verletzt. Was sich nicht umbringt, hat dich vielleicht gebrochen. Das kann man so sagen. Also auch wenn ich jetzt nicht viel mitnehmen konnte aus dem Krankenhaus auf und zählt, außer dass ich alle total nett und toll fand, ist das Sprichwort falsch ist. Es ist, was dich nicht umbringt, hat dich vielleicht hart aus dem Leben genockt. Also du bist jetzt schwächer. Ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen schwächer, ja. Also wird deine eigene Vergänglichkeit dir jetzt mehr bewusst? Ist das jetzt eine Entwicklung in deiner Charaktergeschichte? Also hast du das Gefühl, das ist jetzt ein Punkt, den du in deiner Autobiografie mal ein Kapitel widmen würdest, dass du ab jetzt umschwenkst? Das langweiligste Kapitel, ein langweiliges, kleines, pseudophilosophisches, esoterisches Kapitel. Und auch stark übertrieben, so ich habe an der Tür des Todes geklopft und so, wo man sich fragt, nein, du bist auf dem Schlüsselbein gefallen, du bist aus dem Bett gefallen, Leute brechen sich das. Ich habe das Licht gesehen und mir wurde alles klar und sowas. Genau, und dann auch so esoterisch, aber auch schon ein paar Mal gehört, so Takes wie, seitdem weiß man das Leben zu schätzen, seitdem gehe ich anders durchleben. Du weißt, dein Schlüsselbein zu schätzen, davor war es dir gar nicht bewusst. Vielleicht muss man Dinge erst mal in Gefahr sehen. Schwächlicher, kleiner Knochen, dieses Schlüsselbein. Zu lang und zu dünn. Ja, jetzt ist eine Platte drauf, mir geht's gut, hab die Zeit gut überstanden, ich fand's wirklich, es war super angenehm und Krankenhaus, ohne Scheiß, ist, glaube ich, mein Go-To- Zen-Plan. Also wenn ich mich gut fühlen will, denke ich an diesen Krankenhausaufnahmen, weil du hast immer Leute, die dich um dich kümmern. Ich fand auch das Krankenhaus schön, du hast halt so eine schöne Glasfront gehabt, war am elften Stock, konntest wirklich schön über Köln gucken, nachts überall diese kleinen Lichter noch an, Strassenlaternen an, du hast immer so ein leichtes Gewusel auf dem Flur, aber nicht zu laut, aber du weißt, wenn hier was gerade passiert, Leute sind ganz schnell da, um sich um nichts zu kümmern. Kann man Krankenhaus nicht wie so einen Hotelaufenthalt buchen einfach? Können die nicht dadurch ein bisschen Geld verdienen, dass sie sagen, alle freien Zimmer werden verbucht sozusagen? Ja, weil das, dafür stehen Krankenhäuser ja, die vielen freien Zimmer. Ja gut, für dich war er noch Platz. Für den grossen Podcaster aus München von seiner Show war er anscheinend noch Platz. Freut mich für dich, Stefan. Aber die haben auch zugesehen, dass ich da schnell wieder raus bin. Ja, ja, ich verstehe schon. Gab es einen Fernseher, hast du da Pink Panther geguckt? Es gab einen Fernseher an so einem langen Arm, den habe ich erst lange nicht gesehen, weil er nicht mehr im Blickfeld war. Ich musste hinter mich greifen, konnte er an so einem langen Arm nach vorne ziehen und hatte dann einen Fernseher. Da konnte man viele Sachen anklicken. Mit Kopfhörern oder hat das Markus auch gehört die ganze Zeit? Markus hat auch auf Kopfhörern gehört, aber die hat er so laut, dass ich das ausgehört habe. Das ist ja unangenehm. Ich glaube, ich könnte keinen Spaß daran haben, an irgendeinem Bildschirm, wo noch jemand anders zuschaut. Ich fahre ja auf dem Zug und dort habe ich oft einen guten Platz, wo mich niemand sieht. Aber manchmal ist halt die Situation, man schaut mit seinem Laptop Sachen an und daneben sitzt jemand und der guckt einfach auch zu, obwohl er keinen Ton hat. Und das unangenehmste sind Videos, kennst du wahrscheinlich auch, so Video-Essays, wo einfach die ganze Zeit nur ein Bild zu sehen ist. Wo sich alle fragen. Und ich starre das halt an, schau, höre konzentriert zu und der sitzt neben mir, der hört ja nicht, was ich höre, der denkt sich, der schaut sich jetzt seit 90 Minuten lang einfach nur ein Bild die ganze Zeit an. Führt aber auch ein bisschen vor, wie absurd manche Videos sind. Ja, total. Es könnte ein Podcast sein. Es könnte ein Podcast mit Bild. Habe ich jetzt gesehen, bei Twitch gibt es ja so oft neben den Namen Emojis. So, die einem, nicht Emojis, aber so kleine Symbole, Icons, die einem anzeigen. Das ist ein VIP-Zuschauer. Ah, du meinst im Chat, ja ... Genau, im Chat ein Level-2-Subscriber oder so was.
Und dann gibt es auch ein Auge durchgestrichen,
jemand, der nur hört.
Ja.
Das fand ich ganz gut.
Auch gut, ja.
Twitch kann man natürlich auch gerade diese Just-Chatting-Formate kann man ja einfach hören, wie ein Podcast.
Und das wird aber im Chat dann angezeigt.
Nee, es ist total absurd.
Was für ein Mensch hört nur, schreibt dann aber ...
Ja, das ist schon komisch, ne? Hat dann die Chatebene aber offen, das fand ich auch merkwürdig. Und das ist anscheinend so ein Problem, dass man dann auch noch das als Eichen anzeigen muss. Da wurde, finde ich, zu viel eine Richtung gearbeitet. Oder es ist jemand, der vielleicht gar nicht sehen kann, der einfach dann das anzeigt, dass der andere auf der anderen Seite weiss, okay, der weiss nur, was ich jetzt gesagt habe und nicht, was ich gezeigt habe. Keine Ahnung, ich weiss auch nicht genau. Ist mir so noch nicht aufgefallen. Spannender, spannender. Also ich bin da eh, obwohl ich jetzt seit einiger Zeit streame, kenne ich diese ganzen Symbole überhaupt nicht. Und ich weiss immer nicht, ob die Leute mich verarschen oder nicht, weil halt ständig so willkürliche, also für mich völlig willkürliche Emojis dann, dieser grüne Frosch, und der hat manchmal den auf und manchmal den Hut auf. Was? Also ich gehe einfach davon aus, dass mich jeder verarschen will und jeder trollen will, weil immer irgendwelche willkürlichen Emojis dabei sind. Das ist wirklich schwierig. Das ist eine harte Welt. Das ist wirklich eine harte Welt. Man wird ausgeschlossen. Aber es führt dir halt auch vor, dass du, wenn du im Zug sitzt, dass du es einfach falsch konsumierst, dass du Videos falsch konsumierst. Ich dachte, du meinst was anderes, die typische Sexszene, wenn man was schaut, wo man dann aber kurz, wo ich immer den gleichen Impuls habe. Ich schaue für eine Serie, neben mir guckt jemand mit, bei ihm ist aber das Ohr durchgestrichen, weil er ja nur sieht. So, dann gucke ich und dann kommt eine Sexszene und dann darf man nicht mehr, das ist zumindest mein Empfinden, so gefesselt sein und da hingucken. Man darf aber auch nicht schnell wegschalten. Nee, ich schalte nicht weg, ich mache dann dieses kurze Zurücklehnen, mal auf dem Handy gucken oder mal kurz weg im Raum gucken oder so oder im Zug herum mal aus dem Fenster schauen. Als wüsstest du dich, was die da machen. Als wärst du, weil du nicht verstehst, was da passiert. Achso, für dich ist das so normal.
Nicht Google rausholen und Geschlechtsverkehr googlen, eher ein bisschen gelangweilt sein von dem, was da gerade zu sehen ist. Das ist ja ganz normal. Ich bin ja wegen der anderen Szenen hier, dem intellektuellen Austausch zwischen den Figuren. Das ist auch weird. Nee, find ich gut. Ist auch immer, wenn ein Kind daneben sitzt und man dann so bewusst coole Sachen macht oder bewusst uncoole Sachen oder dann sich überlegt, wie viel Brutalität ist normal. Ich schau sehr brutale Videos normalerweise. Und auch so Videospiele oder so, weiss man auch nicht genau, ist immer schwierig. Schwierig. Ich schloss immer deine Gore ab 18 Videos. Die hebe ich mir immer für die Zugfahrt auf. Die lade ich mir schön runter. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Gore und, oder so Splatter und Operationsvorbereitungsvideos? Einverständnis des Opfers wahrscheinlich, kann sein, ich weiß nicht. Ach so, ich wollte jetzt von Fiction ausgehen. Ach so. Fiction und Operationsvideos. Brutale Fiction, Saw und Operationsvideos. Der Übergang ist wirklich fliessend. Für Kinder nebenan beides nicht gut. Ja, stimmt. Für mich auch beides nicht so gut. Naja, das sei jedenfalls sehr, ich fände es interessant, einfach wirklich den Knochen anzusehen wie eine Wand, wo man einfach, kannst du reinschrauben und die Schraube sieht genauso aus. Aber was ist Knochenmark? Das Innere eines Knochenmark, die Seele. Aber das ist nicht so, weil, also ich verstehe auch schon Zahn nicht, weil Leute sagen, Zahn kann man, also Zähne tun weh, weil da ist ein Nerv innen drin, Aber von aussßen, wie kommt das ran, verstehe ich nicht. Und dann beim Knochen, also Knochen spüren ja nichts, aber das Mark ist. Zähne tun ja nur weh, wenn, wie ich es verstehen verstanden habe. Der Nerv offen liegt, oder was? Genau, weil Bakterien sich in den Tunnel graben. Und da ist dann überhaupt nur ein Nerv drin. Grabt weiter! Tief! Das will ich nämlich so eine, es war in meinem Leben artige
Serie, nur mit den
Steaks, nicht so kindlich und animiert,
sondern so Live-Action,
aber dann mit den Steaks wie so Herr der Ringe,
so Fantasy. Ja. Und die Bakterien
sind wie so Orks, die sagen,
Grabt weiter! Ja.
Aber wir haben schon zu tief gegraben.
Grabt weiter!
Arr!
Asaf sagt, Lord Asaf sagt, weiter! Und die Orks gruben zu tief und sie wussten nicht, was sie dort fand. Gruben zu tief und zu gierig. Und dann kam so ein Nerv, so ein heller Nerv, wird freigeschafft. Genau, wie so Mitri, ja, so glitzernd und dann schlagen sie rein und dann schnitt so, hm, nochmal irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ein bisschen Zahnschmerzen hier rechts unten, keine Ahnung, was da los ist. Warum fliegen die Adler aus dem Mund? Hä, warum fliegen die Adler Gondors aus dem Mund? Hä, warum holst du nicht einfach die Adler? Ja. Da wird die Serie dann merkwürdig an dem Punkt. Merkwürdig selbstreferenziell.
Ich glaube, ich muss zu Elrond und mich heilen lassen. Hä, warum wirfst du denn den Ring nicht einfach ins Feuer mit den Adlern? Wirfst du denn? Ach, es ist schwierig. Logiklücken, es ist schwierig. Du hast gerade vor der Aufnahme in so einem Nebensatz gesagt, dass du, vielleicht darfst du es nicht sagen, da kannst du direkt wieder das Thema wechseln, unbemerkt, aber dass du mit dem Tolkien-Verband in Verbindung stehst. Naja, nicht intensiv natürlich, aber man ist im Gespräch. Allen Ernstes und sagt, ich bin im Gespräch mit der Tolkien-Gesellschaft. Ich finde das aber alleine so geil, dass es eine Tolkien-Gesellschaft gibt. Ich finde, dass die in Gesprächen sind gut. Ja, ich finde es auch gut, dass sie so einen Rat haben und dass sie dann neun Ringe unter sich verteilen. Das sind neun Leute. Das sind neun Leute, jeder hat einen Ring und die reiten auf schwarzen Pferden. Und ich frage mich, habt ihr das Buch gelesen? Also wisst ihr, wohin das geht? Oder habt ihr nur die ersten Seiten gelesen, war so gehypt, dass ihr sagt, das machen wir auch, aber ihr wisst gar nicht, wie es ausgeht. Es ist auf jeden Fall fantastisch. Wild. Es ist richtig wild, ja. Also das finde ich geil. Und dann, was, worüber redet ihr? Ach, du schaust ja die Serie. Über Blumen, über die verschiedenen Blumen. Das ist ein Austausch, aber jetzt nicht per se über Tolkiens Werke. Nein, nein, nein, nein, das nicht. Da geht es also viel um, also Klaus sucht eine neue Wohnung und ich gebe da so ein bisschen Tipps und so, Immobilienmarkt und. Dann würde ich das anders formulieren, weil dann fand ich es jetzt irgendwie komisch misleading, dass du zu mir gesagt hast, du bist im Gespräch mit der Tolkengesellschaft. Ach so, nee, nee, aber nicht über Tolkeng. Ja, ja, aber dann würde ich es anders formulieren. Dann sagt er sowas wie, ich bin im Gespräch mit Klaus Behrensen. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Behrensen. Nee, weil das ist ganz merkwürdig, bei Clara, die hat jetzt so eine neue Waschmaschine und ist irgendwie immer nach jedem Waschgang ist da so eine Pfütze Wasser drunter so und dann ist immer nicht klar, wann genau passiert das. Jetzt habe ich ihr mal angeboten, weil ich habe so eine GoPro, habe ich ihr mal angeboten, dass ich die bei ihr aufstelle, also sie stellt das auf natürlich, und dann filmt sie mal die Waschmaschine halt durch den ganzen Zyklus mal durch, um zu sehen, wann diese Pfütze entsteht, weil ich glaube, dadurch kann man dann vielleicht so ein bisschen gucken, wo genau das Problem ist. Wie gesagt, ich will es nicht formulieren, das ganze Thema wird nicht formulieren, ich bin Gesprächen mit der Tolkien-Gesellschaft, es sei denn, ein Ork wäre das Problem, der Pfützen vor der Waschmaschine. Nee, nee, nee. Kein Ork. Nee, kein Ork. Kein Elb. Nee, Kalk wahrscheinlich eher. Also Kalk könnte der Feind hier sein. Okay, Kalk der Elbenkönig. Nein, nein, nein, Kalk, einfach nur Kalk. Okay, und das wurde von den Zwergen in Moria geschürft. Das ist halt das Problem, weil man müsste dann auch mal gucken, wie hoch der Kalkgewert in dem Wasser ist. Okay, und Zwerge auch nicht?
Nee.
Okay, hat klarerhaarige Füsse?
Nein.
Dann formulier es anders.
Ich habe nichts zu tun haben.
Dann formulier das Thema bitte anders.
Warum hat man nicht unter den Sohlenhaaren eigentlich?
So wie so Schuhe? Aber haben ja Tiere auch nicht. Sind Handschuhe nicht eher Handsocken? So, und jetzt glaube ich, jetzt haben wir einen Punkt. Sorry. Sind Handschuhe nicht eher Handsocken? Ist ein guter Punkt, ja. Es sind nicht Schuhe. Nee, es sind keine Schuhe. It's far away from Schuhe. Nee, es sind wirklich keine Schuhe. Es sind eher Socken. Das heißt, auch das Handschuhfach müsste man ins Handsockenfach nochmal komplett neu umdenken. Ich habe eh das Gefühl, dass Handschuhe verschwinden so ein bisschen. Also ich habe jetzt, also als Kind waren Handschuhe ein Riesenthema. Immer heutzutage, ich habe eigentlich seit Jahren keine Handschuhe mehr angehabt. Ich will einen Twitter-Account oder irgendwie eine Website, wo man gucken kann, wie das Handschuhe-Fäustlinge-Verhältnis ist. Zu jedem Zeitpunkt. Ja, einfach mal so gegeneinander aufwiegen. Weil ich glaube, Fäustlinge machen gerade, erleben einen Revival. Wirklich? Fäustlinge. Ja. Du weißt, was ich meine mit Fäustlingen. Ich weiß, was du meinst. Ruchst du dich ein bisschen fragend an. Ich weiss absolut, was du meinst. Ich stehe seit Jahren mit der Richard-Wagner-Gesellschaft in einem Gespräch über Fäustlingen. Nee, ist eine gute Möglichkeit. Ich fand die immer cooler als Kind, weil die haben so was Boxhandschuhiges und ich habe mich immer stark gefühlt mit Fäustlingen. Ich finde die süss, man fühlt sich irgendwie, man trennt diechen auch nicht die bleiben zusammen ich finde das alles beruhigend daran und so und es sieht auch irgendwie niedlich aus die Füsse sind ja wie eine grosse Familie das sind zwei Familien einfach die sind zu fünft in Schuhen, die sind zu fünft in Socken, die sind einfach zusammen wohingegen die Hände, da haben die Finger sich so ein bisschen entlebt, habe ich das Gefühl die Die machen ihr eigenes Ding, da hat jeder einen eigenen Namen. Die Zehen haben nicht mal eigenen Namen. Du hast nur die Zehen. Familie Zehen. Ja, das sind die Zehen. Familie Zehen, Juli und der Rest. Aber ja, das sehe ich ganz genau. Das ist einfach eine Familie. Ausser bei Flipflops. Und deswegen mag ich Flipflops auch glaube ich nicht. So, ja, jetzt haben wir ein Problem. Weil der große Onkel sagt, hm, ich bin ein bisschen was Besseres. Ich nehme mein Einzelzimmer. Das ist Flippflop. Flippflop sagt, der grosse Onkel, nehme mir mein Einzelzimmer. Wohingegen Sandalen halten die Gemeinschaft zusammen. Wunderbar. Was ich auch nicht mag, sind diese Sockenschuhe. Die trennen die nämlich auch. Nee, man darf die nicht trennen. Die sind ein Team. Die stützen ja alles, so wenn die die eigene Ding machen.
Du meinst, man trägt Schuhe an den Händen oder was?
Oder wo bist du jetzt?
Füssen, pass auf, diese Füsse, wir hatten einen, das ist ein Spanischlehrer.
Fussschuhe meinst du?
Fussschuhe, ja.
Aber die sind weniger Schuh als Handschuh, weißt du, was ich meine?
Die sind wie Handschuhe aus, nur für Füsse.
Ja, ja, nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht. Die sind so weit weg von Schuhen, das sind ja eher Socken. Ja, ja, ja. Ja, stimmt schon. Aber gut, der Daumen ist natürlich der Querschläger, der ist offensichtlich anders als die anderen. Aber ich finde zumindest, dass die vier noch zusammenhalten können, das finde ich gut als Fäustlinge, dass man dann sagt, dann lassen sie als Vierergruppe noch Gemeinschaft sein, der Daumen ist so außen und... Ja, und Fäustlinge sagen auch so, Hände haben Urlaub. Hände haben jetzt Urlaub. Ich stelle mir vor, dass die vier dann so an so einem Kaminfeuer sitzen. Genau. Und auch mal so, der ganze Stress fällt ab. Fällt ab, beide Hände an so einer heißen Tasse Tee. Und diese, weil man kann mit diesen Fäustlingen ja auch keine schweren Arbeiten verrichten. Nein. Du kannst damit nicht zeichnen, du kannst damit keine Kunstwerke vollbringen. Das ist für dich schwere Arbeiten? Ja, gedanklich. Gut, aber du kannst damit auch keine Schlüsselbeineoperationen machen. Stimmt, aber Holzfällen kannst du trotzdem. Aber ich verstehe, was du meinst. Einziger Nachteil von Fäustlingen, du kannst niemandem den Finger geben. Das sieht halt immer sehr albern aus. Im Straßenverkehr. Und du halt stocksauer wütend einfach die ganze Hand hochhegst. Vier Fingerzeig. Das ist halt der einzige Nachhalt. Das sieht aus wie die vierte Verwarnung. Aber noch dummer ist, wenn du erst die Handschuhe ausziehen musst. Hey, du hast nicht geschnitten, du Arschloch! Musst du erst den Handschuhe ausziehen. Das klappt auch nicht. Das ist zu viel Kontrolle in der Wut. Es geht auch viel Wut in deinem Gesicht verloren, wenn du darüber ja auch wahrscheinlich so eine Mütze hast mit diesen dicken Schlappohren. Und dem Bommel. Winter ist keine Wutzeit. Die Emotionen werden gedämpft durch einfach die Kleidung. Der Bommel untergräbt dein Wut. Jederzeit. Habt ihr mal Bommelmützen tragende Menschen in Prügeleien gesehen?
Ich nicht. Nee, stimmt. Nee, es geht nicht. Nee, der Bommel verhindert ein, sagen wir mal, kohärentes Wutbild. Absolut. Das ist richtig. Ich meine, der Weihnachtsmann, nicht umsonst, ich kann mir den nicht vorstellen in irgendeiner gewaltsamen Auseinandersetzung. Es geht nicht. Aber Zip Zipfel ist natürlich noch was anderes. Das ist, da würde ich mal sagen. Meiner ich jetzt zu stark. Also jetzt wird es mir zu weit, zu plakativ wird es mir jetzt. Aber es stimmt so, eine schöne Bommelmütze oder mit so Katzenohren oder so, das hat schon was, das ist einfach was Deeskalierendes, das stimmt schon. Ich muss kurz die Community fragen, weil ich habe ein kleines Problem, und zwar stirbt mein grosser Gummibaum. Ist es wirklich ein grosser Baum? Der ist so zwei Meter noch was gross. Mein grosser Gummibaum stirbt einen tragischen Tod. Die Blätter werden gelb und fallen ab. Dieses traurigste Weihnachtslied. Oh Gummibaum, oh Gummibaum, warum die ganzen gelben Blätter? Was machst du eigentlich bei mir? Produzierst kein Gummi, nichts für mich. Oh Gummibaum, oh Gummibaum, wie gelbs sind deine Blätter? Sie fallen ab, man glaubt es kaum, auf den Boden mit nem Riesenknall. Oh Gummibaum, oh Gummibaum, wie grösst du dein! Damit ist offiziell die Weihnachtszeit eingeleitet. So schade, weil der ist so schön und groß und cool. Okay, aber für uns kurz rein. Gummibaum heißt, der Baum ist nicht aus Gummi, das ist ein Fehler, den ich jetzt vermeide, sondern er produziert Gummi, um daraus Gummibäume zu machen, die dann aber aus Gummi sind. Naja, ich glaube, das kommt schon daher, dass der Kautschuk produziert. Eine weitere Art oder Überart oder so ist wahrscheinlich der Kautschukbaum, keine Ahnung. Zurück zu meinem, ich glaube, der heisst Ficus Elasticus oder Elastica, nagelt mich nicht auf den lateinischen Namen fest, der ist mir in Nolens Volens entfallen. Ich möchte nur sagen, Ficus Elasticus, glaube ich, ist ein grosser Baum, er ist Stamm, oben Krone, ist total schick und dem ging es jahrelang gut.
Und erntest du denn Gummi auch oder nicht?
Es wird nicht geerntet. Es ist ein reines Zirdeobjekt.
Ja, aber ist es nicht, aber hemmst du den nicht, wenn du nicht erntst? Also ist es nicht, einerseits verschenkt, aber ist es nicht auch so bei Schafen, dass wenn man die nicht schert, dass die dann abhauen oder dann irgendwie zu einer Wolke werden oder so? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, wir haben keine Überproduktion
von Gummi.
Aber vielleicht ist das das Problem.
Ich bin jedenfalls offen für alle Vorschläge.
Also meine
Walking Theory ist ein bisschen,
das steht vor einem Fenster
und da kommt zum Meinen viel Licht rein.
Eigentlich müsste es ihm gut gehen,
ging es ihm auch jahrelang.
Jetzt sieht er aber sehr stark, dass alle Bäume draußen gelb werden.
Nimmt er das wahr? Meine Frage ist, glaube ich, kommunizieren Bäume miteinander.
Visuell. Die Bäume, nee, muss nicht mal. Hauen die Bäume vielleicht irgendwelche Formen von Botenstoff oder sowas aus, die sagen, so, es ist der Time of the Year, wir werden jetzt alle gelb, schmeißt eure Blätter ab, sonst frieren euch die Adern in den Ästen. Weißt du? Und du meinst, obwohl es gar keine anderen Gummibäume gibt in deiner Nähe, nimmt der das trotzdem wahr? Also der hat den Kölner Dialekt mittlerweile gelernt. Der versteht mittlerweile die Einheimischen. Genau. Ja, ich glaube, dieser aus f hat einfach ein paar Jahre gebraucht. Aus Fernlanden, der Gummibaum, ist jetzt in Köln angekommen. Okay, ist jetzt ein Kölscher-Jung. Kölscher-Jung. Am 11.11. sind die Blätter ab, sage ich mal. Okay, also da hat er sich mittlerweile eingelebt, was ja gut ist. Ihre Feld, Radatal, Nippes, Gummibaum in Silz. Das heißt aber, du hast jetzt Angst, dass er sozusagen die falsche Entscheidung trifft, konformistisch auch gelbt, obwohl das für ihn eigentlich gar nicht gut ist. Genau. Also Gruppenzwang macht den Gummibaum kaputt. Genau, Peer Pressure Baum. Ja. Und der schmeißt jetzt ab, ohne zu wissen, was die Langzeitfolgen seines Handelns jetzt sind.
Okay. Nämlich, er hat keine Blätter mehr.
Und ich habe einen kahlen Baum in meiner Wohnung.
Also du kommst jetzt mit Argumenten wie,
ja, wenn die anderen Bäume von der Brücke springen würden,
würdest du das auch machen, sowas. Genau,
das wäre in meiner pädagogischen Herangehensweise, stand schon
vor dem Baum und gesagt, aber es geht nicht.
Nur weil draußen
alle das so machen, musst du das nicht auch machen.
Ja. Wir haben
gelbe Blätter zu Hause, mässig. Oder du gehst zu den anderen Bäumen und sagst, Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich, was ihr für einen Einfluss auf meinen Gummibaum habt? Nur weil ihr hier jetzt alle anfangt mit gelben Blättern. Ihr seid auch älter, ihr seid auch älter, ihr solltet es eigentlich besser wissen. Der ist jünger, der muss das nicht machen, der braucht keine gelben Blätter. Ihr könnt dem auch ein Vorbild sein, anstatt sowas vorzulesen. Es ist auch okay, anders zu sein. Es ist auch okay, seine Blätter, wenn man nämlich drinnen steht, den das ganze Jahr über zu behalten. Stefan, hör auf, mit denen zu hängen. Nein, aber das stimmt doch. Ja, nein, das ist peinlich. Hast du wegen denen da draußen angefangen, Geryl da zu bekommen? Nein, das ist meine eigene Entscheidung. Riech ich hier Bre? Rieche Botenstoffe? Nein.
Also es ist... Riecht es doch in deinem Zimmer nach Botenstoffen.
Also dein Gummibaum ist in der Pubertät und du musst gucken, wie schafft er es zu einem eigenschnittenen Erwachsenenleben.
Das ist jetzt gerade die Aufgabe.
Mängelos bei dir gerade.
Mit der Verletzung jetzt ein neuer Mensch geworden, Gummibaum.
Ich kam nach Hause.
Jetzt könnte man natürlich böse Stimmen behaupten.
Du hast ja bei der Zeit nicht gegossen.
Deswegen sind die gelb, der stirbt hier weg.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Verletzung, jetzt ein neuer Mensch geworden, Gummibaum. Ich kam nach Hause, jetzt könnte man natürlich böse Stimmen behaupten, du hast ja bei der Zeit nicht gegossen, deswegen sind die gelb, der stirbt hier weg.
Das Problem ist aber, wenn man bei Gummibäumen eingibt, die Blätter werden gelb, dann irgendwann braun, fallen ab, was übrigens auch nicht so trivial ist, weil das sehr laut ist, weil es sind grosse Blätter und ich wach davon auf. Das ist kein Scheiß.
Wow!
Nee, aber es ist nachts einfach so ein und man denkt, es ist wie jemand, der einmal in einer Wohnung klatscht. Und es ist schon irritierend. So ein Einbrecher, der sich reinschleicht und dann einmal ... Ja, und dann geht er wieder aus. Und dann aber nichts mehr. Und guckt, ob du aufstehst. Ja, genau. So ist es ein bisschen, ich wach davon auf und nehm mir, war das gerade? Gemein. ist doch wie ein Buch umgekippt. Nein, es ist ein Blatt vom Gummibäum gefallen. Und dann ... Das ist ein Hilferuf, Stefan. Ich weiß, der hilft um Rufe. Und dann habe ich gegoogelt, was das genau bedeutet und es steht, ja, entweder haben sie zu A, also Troubleshooting war A, zu viel gegossen, B, zu wenig gegossen. und da hört es bei mir jetzt schon auf, weil nichts machen ist dann offensichtlich die Lösung. Wenn es ihm schlechter geht, habe ich zu wenig gegossen, wenn es ihm besser geht, habe ich zu viel gegossen. Oder kann ich irgendwas Staunässe, war häufig so ein Schlagwort, was ich gelesen habe, weiß nicht genau, was das bedeutet, ich glaube, zu viel Wasser unten im Topf, was dann steht und irgendwie fault oder sowas, habe ich nicht genau verstanden, ist glaube ich nicht das Problem. Ich habe es paar Jahre lang gewollt, was ich gelesen habe. Ich weiß nicht genau, was das bedeutet.
Ich glaube, zu viel Wasser unten im Topf, was dann steht und fault.
Habe ich nicht verstanden, ist nicht das Problem.
Ich habe es gedüngt, aber ich brauche eure Hilfe.
Ich brauche die Botaniker von euch da draußen.
Habt ihr ähnliche Fälle, wer hat eure Gummibäume?
Es ist Herbst, weil der Herbst Einzug hält.
Aber wenn es das erste Mal ist, das passiert ja unwahrscheinlich.
Wir machen die Leitung auf, 0800, Gummi ist frei, ruft an, wir brauchen eure Hilfe für Leute, die vielleicht da Erfahrung haben. Wir machen mit Kautschuk. Und natürlich die Möglichkeit, da auch ein bisschen, also ich würde sagen, der Gewinner kriegt dann aber auch eine Ladung Gummi. Dann gibst du Gummi. Dann gebe ich ein bisschen Gummi, okay. Das finde ich sollte schon fair sein, wenn da jemand hilft. Also ich meine, es ist auch bei Ärzten auch so, die nehmen sich auch so ein bisschen Blut mit, oder? So, als Bezahlung. Vanessa, du bist ja acht Jahre alt und du hast es hier ins Halbfjahrneider geschafft. Dein Wort ist Naturkautschuk. Ich wiederhole, Naturkautschuk. N. Richtig?
Wir wollen alle nach Hause. Niemand will hier sein. S-C-H-U-K. Ja, Naturkautschuk. Wuhu! Yes! Macht der Vater im Publikum. Papa! Fuck yes! Fuck yes! War die erste Runde Hein, Heinrich. Fuck me, die Kleine hat es geschafft. Heinrich, das war die allererste Runde, Heinrich, letztlich. Fuck yeah. USA! USA! Fängt an zu schwenken. Papa! Mit so einem Make-It-Very-Great-Again-Cappy mit so einem riesengroßen Bier in der Hand sitzt er da mit so einer T-Shirt-Kanone. Ja. Ach ja, Fan. Ich wäre gerne richtig Fan von irgendwas. Du bist Fan. Du bist Fan von Dota 2 OG. Ja, vielleicht habt ihr es schon bemerkt, ich bin schlapp, ich bin müde, ich bin entkernt quasi. Und das liegt daran, dass aktuell wieder The International läuft, das grösste Dota-Tournier des Jahres. Zwei Wochen lang feinste Dota-Unterhaltung, ganz viele Spiele, toll. Das Problem ist nur, dieses Ereignis findet immer an unterschiedlichen Orten in der Welt statt, damit auch in unterschiedlichen Zeitzonen. Wir Formel-1-Fans, may I add, wir für meinen Teil Ex-Formel-1-Fans. Da verändert sich so viel gerade. Ohne Schlüsselbein, ohne mich. Bei Formel-1, nee, aber ist das ja genauso, da kennt man das. In vielen Sporten ist das Problem, dass die Welt einfach verschiedene Zeitzonen hat. Nee, gut, aber zum Beispiel bei der Fussballweltmeisterschaft, da ist es doch egal, wann die ist, die Spiele sind noch immer für deutsche Augen gemacht. Ja, ich glaube, das ist da unser Standortvorteil, weil hier in Mitteleuropa die meisten Fans sind. Genau. Aber ich glaube, bei vielen Sachen ist es auch nicht so. So, und bei Dota ist es eben nicht so, und da ist es manchmal super und manchmal furchtbar, und aktuell ist es in Singapur und damit auch teilweise wirklich furchtbare Zeiten, also die ersten Spiele gehen dann so zwei, vier, sechs Uhr morgens los oder so.
Scheiße.
Und da muss man sich dann immer überlegen, steht man früh auf, macht man durch, so furchtbar, also die nächsten zwei Wochen werden jetzt auf jeden Fall hart für mich, aber da muss man durch, da muss man eben durch und deswegen, falls ihr mich antrefft, ich bin schlapp, ich bin müde, mein Biorhythmus funktioniert nicht mehr. Ja. Wollte ich nur mal gesagt haben. Hast du denn die fantastische neue Serie, die ich noch nicht gesehen habe, aber glaube ich, ist der toll, Players geschaut? Nein. Von American Vandal-Machern, die haben eine Serie über die Rollteam. Ach,oll, okay. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Kann ich auf Basis der wenigen Sachen, die ich davon gesehen und gelesen habe, nur empfehlen. Bislang uneingeschränkt. Ja, gerne, schau ich mir an, glaube ich, ist ein cooles Thema auf jeden Fall. Paramount Plus, ein neuer Streaming-Anbieter. Ach Gott, schon wieder. Streaming-Landschaft Quo Vadis. Nein, was, Quo Vadis? Ist da das Quo? Ja, Quo Vadis, wo geht's hin? Was passiert? Streaminglandschaft Deutschland. Wie geht's weiter? Ach, das ist furchtbar. Naja, ich bin mittlerweile so weit, dass ich bei manchen Streaming-Services die Angebote gar nicht mehr wahrnehmen kann, weil die Player nicht laufen, zum Beispiel bei manchen Streaming, dass ich für Streaming-Sendungen, die ich bezahlt habe, sie trotzdem illegal schaue. Ja. Das ist einfach albern. Ja, mein Grund ist auch, warum ich Ex-Formel-1-Fan bin, dass ich für Streamingsendungen, die ich bezahlt habe, sie trotzdem illegal schaue.
Ja.
Das ist einfach albern.
Ja, mein Grund ist auch, warum ich Ex-Formel-1-Fan bin, weil ich Sky nicht ertrage und das jetzt gekündigt habe.
Und das sind mal 40 Euro im Monat gekostet. Ich habe da keine Lust drauf.
Also deswegen, Formel-1 fährt jetzt ohne mich weiter im Kreis herum, denn das ist ja auch, wenn man mal böse ist, alles was sie tun.
Und das ohne mich jetzt. Aber es wird nicht mehr derselbe Sport sein unter dich, glaube ich. Deine Stimme fehlt. Meine kleine, heisere Stimme. Deine kleine, heisere Stimme fehlt einfach so. Ich glaube, da wird sich der Sport lange nicht von erholen, aber dann geht es wieder einigermaßen. Ich habe eine Frage an dich, weil das ist ja hier auch der große gesellschaftliche Geflogenheiten-Podcast, wie geht man mit Dingen um, was sollte man tun, der Knigge-Cast. Meine Frage ist, weil das Fitnessstudio, in dem ich bin, ist super nett, denn man kriegt Geburtstagsgeschenke. Sie ist die Fitnessstudio-E-Mail-Adresse, ist immer jedes Jahr die erste Adresse, die mir gratuliert zum Geburtstag. Ja. Denken immer sehr früh an mich und dann heißt es immer, wir haben ein Geschenk für dich, es liegt an der Rezeption für dich zum Abholen bereit.
Jetzt bin ich davon ausgegangen, dass man dann, und mein Geburtstag ist im August, nur kurz zur Einordnung, ich habe es immer noch nicht, weil meine Idee war, wie geil, dann kommt man da hin, lockt sich dann ein, kommt vorne durch dieses Tor, Drehtor und dann sagen die, ja, wir sehen hier, da ist so ein Geburtstagseicon unten rechts, sie haben das Geburtstagskrieg noch nicht bekommen, hier also ein Glückwunsch und dann kriegt man irgendwie was in der Hand gedrückt, keine Ahnung, Proteinshake, was auch immer, Proteinriegel oder ein Handtuch oder so. Ähm, nein. Turns out, man muss die ansprechen. So, jetzt ist mittlerweile der 17. Oktober, wenn die Folge rauskommt, noch später. Ich werde da noch nicht hingegangen sein. Macht man das denn? Wie clever ist das quasi? Weil trotzdem, die sind bei mir in die Kategorie sehr gute Menschen gerutscht, weil sie mir tendenziell ein Geschenk machen wollen. Jetzt haben sie Jubiläum gehabt, haben gesagt, wir haben für alle Mitglieder ein Jubiläumsgeschenk. Sprechen Sie uns bei der Rezeption an. Die Frage ist natürlich, ist das jetzt ein Geschenk wie so aus dem Happy Meal, wo da einfach ein Karton unter der Theke liegt, wo jeder, der sagt, er hatte Geburtstag, kriegt da so ein Ding in die Hand gedrückt, ohne dass da irgendwas ist. Oder halten die das wirklich für dich zurück und es stapelt sich schon deine Geschenke und dann sagen die, wann kommt denn der Stefan endlich und dann irgendwann müssen sie sagen, jetzt weg.
Aber die sehen ja meinen Namen, wenn ich mich da einlogge. Ich komme rein, melde mich an, so ein Armbandding und dann gehe ich so.
Das heißt, da müssten sie ja, denke ich mir, das System ist ja falsch, aber dieses, ich finde das so clever von denen und da habe ich überlegt, wie kriegt man das auch noch implementiert im Leben, weil in gewisser Weise machen sie nichts, sie erbringen keine Zusatzleistung, weil ich glaube, ein Bruchteil der Mitglieder holt dieses Jubiläumgeschenk ab, weil man da nicht hingeht und sagt, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nur fragen, sie haben noch ein Geschenk für mich. Das ist das Unangenehmste der Welt. Ja. Ne, so funktionieren Geschenke auch nicht. Der, der das Geschenk hat, geht auf dich zu und sagt, hier ist das Geschenk. In dem Moment, in dem du als Bittsteller gehst und sagst, ich habe heute Geburtstag, hast du ein Geschenk für mich? Ja, genau. Das ist extrem unangenehm, unangemessen funktioniert so nicht. So funktioniert Geschenken nicht. Aber es ist gewisserweise ein Loophole, was die da gesellschaftlich hinbekommen haben, denn man hat ja sich als Schenker abgespeichert. Als schenkende Mensch. Wow, da hat jemand ein Geburtstagsgeschenk von mir, von dem ich es nicht erwartet hätte. Ein Fitnessstudio. Ich würde versuchen, dort aufzutauchen und durch Körpersprache, Aussehen und Kleidung zu symbolisieren, dass heute mein Geburtstag ist. Ich denke da an so eine Krone, so einen Partyhut. Es gibt ja diese Ballons mit den Zahlen, mit den Ziffern.
Da steht dann schön zwei, sieben, zwei, acht, irgendwie sowas.
Also hinten.
Also je nachdem.
Je nachdem.
Und dann kommst du da an und ohne dass du das jetzt explizit aussprichst,
sollte die Rezeption wissen, ah, da hat jemand Geburtstag.
Und dann da so vorbeilaufen.
Ganz langsam. Hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, ah, da hat jemand Geburtstag und dann da so vorbeilaufen. Ganz langsam. Du hast auch schon ein Stück Torte in der Hand, du bist gut drauf. Oh, Entschuldigung, haben Sie heute Geburtstag? Entschuldigung, meine Torte, köstlich. Ja, wir kommen darauf, heute ist eine Geburt ja, dann alles Gutes zum Glück. Wir haben sogar ein Geschenk für Sie. Nein, ja, doch. Und das vorletztes Jahr? Ach so, oder muss ich jetzt ... Ins Lager. Oder muss ich kurz ins Lager. Immer so ein riesiger Atombunker mit tausenden Geschenken, die nicht abgeholt wurden. Die da so traurig sitzen. Das Ende von Indiana Jones, diese Riesenhalle, so traurig, aber so Riesenkisten. Glauben Sie mich, holt noch jemand ab? Nein, das tut mir leid. Der ist noch nicht gekommen für sein Geburtstagsgeschenk. Naja, vielleicht nächstes Jahr. Was? Ich bin, heute ist mein erster Tag hier, und es hat jemand nach, ich soll dich bringen. Was bist du genau? Endlich, ich krieg eine Familie! Darf ich dich genau fragen, was du bist, kleiner Charakter? Ich bin der Pavel und ich warte schon seit Jahren auf eine Familie. Pavel, was bist du? Ich bin ein Waisenjunge und ich warte schon so lange auf eine nette Familie, die mich aufnimmt. Tom, Tom, ich bin jetzt bei dem Geschenk, es spricht mit merkwürdigen Akzent nicht so richtig zuordnen. Ja genau, das ist das Geburtstagsgeschenk. Geschenken, Waisenkinder? Ja, natürlich. Aber der Mann ist inzwischen 32 Jahre alt wahrscheinlich, Pavel ist 32 Jahre alt. Naja. Es ist nicht so ganz eindeutig zu erkennen, wie alt er ist. Es ist nicht unsere Schuld, dass die Leute ihre Geburtstagsgeschenke nicht abholen. Ich meine, das ist schade, aber naja. Okay, Pavel, wir bringen dich in ein neues Zuhause. Oh, was für eine Freude! Was für ein Tag für mich! Aber leider alles voller Leute. Niemand holt die ab. Aber so würde ich es auf jeden Fall machen. Also mit Geburtstagsanzug da aufkommen, Dick the Birthday Boy oder so, irgendwas auf dem T-Shirt stehen haben. Kiss the Birthday Boy. Sowas, dass man einfach weiß, dass du Geburtstag hast. Aber du hast recht, es ist eine Umkehrung der Machtverhältnisse. Man darf nicht Leute dazu auffordern, ihr Geschenk einzufordern. Das geht nicht. Ich kenne mich richtig katholisch vor, so ein richtiger, guter Katholizist, weil meine anrichtigste T-Shirt-Idee war
Mary the Birthday Boy.
Es war nicht Kiss
the Birthday Boy oder Fuck
the Birthday Boy, sondern Mary
und dann so ein anrichtiger Zwinker-Smiley.
Mary the Birthday Boy.
Nee, nee, ein bisschen mehr als Kiss.
Stefan, du bist ein Bad Boy geworden,
habe ich das Gefühl. Du bist ein richtiger Bad Boy. Aber dieser kleine, unschuldige Zahnspangen-Messdiener ist noch in mir drin. Total, absolut. Mary the Birthday Boy. Ladies, Mary the Birthday Boy. Also ich finde, du hast recht, es ist merkwürdig, das glaube ich, könnte man in jeder Firma so machen. Übrigens, ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag, automatisierte E-Mail, du kannst dir bei der Rezeption, bei Carsten kannst du dir irgendwie das Geschenk abholen oder so. Und Carsten hat dann irgendwie so einen ganzen Eimer voll Flaschenöffner oder so und dann sagt er, ja, kriegt jeder einen. Aber der hat doch heute gar nicht Geburtstag. Ja, wir geben es jedem aus. Es ist mir doch scheißegal. Es kommt niemand, die abholen, es geht nicht jedem. Es ist mir doch scheißegal. Wir müssen einen Tag raus, wo niemand Geburtstag hat, damit es fair ist. Heute kriegt jeder so einen Flaschenöffner. Ich bin hier, um die Flaschenöffner rauszugeben, wem oder was ist mir egal. Wem oder was muss ich hier inblasen, um diese Flaschenöffner loszuwerden.
Ja, genau. Ich kann nicht jeden nach einem Namen fragen, oder was, ich weiß nicht, wie die heissen, oder was.
Hier, die Namen, der Firmenlogo ist faul draufgemalt.
Die sind ganz billig, tausend Stück haben hier noch im Lager, die in meinem Auto hängen die.
Mein ganzer Kofferraum ist voll mit den scheiß Flaschenöffnern.
Sieht aus wie ein Fehldruck, alles voll mit dem Fiat-Covid.
Fiat-Covid. Fiat-Covid. Ganz im Kofferraum von meinem Fiat-Covid. Ah, mein alter Fiat-Covid. Ich starte ihn kurz. Ah, das ist ein ungünstiger Name.
2008 Baujahr, 2018 Baujahr.
Der erste Fiat-Covid gegen 2018, gegen Stolz 2018 vom Band.
Gegen Stolz 2018 auf die deutschen Strassen über.
Der Fiat-Covid bringt dich sicher und gesund ans Ziel, ohne Probleme mit der neuen Entlüftungsanlage, Durchlüftungsanlage auf den deutschen Strassen, Fiat-Covid. Ich bin immer noch hüsterisch, es hört nicht auf, ich habe das Gefühl, gewisse Dinge sind in einem Normalzustand, ab einem gewissen Punkt hustet man einfach. Es gibt Leute, die einfach husten. Ja, und sich stöhnen, wenn sie sich hinsetzen. Da habe ich auch jetzt angefangen. Ich stöhne viel jetzt, weil jede Bewegung mich an meinen Unheil erinnert. Es ist so nervig, ohne Scheiß, wenn dein Unfall ist, ein bisschen gewisserweise meiner Dummheit zuzuschreiben. Und es ist so schlimm. Es ist so schlimm, weil dich jede, du bist so, du bist doppelt und dreifach dafür bestraft, weil du wirklich bei jeder Bewegung, die dir ein bisschen wehtut, an diese doofe Entscheidung deines Lebens erinnert wirst. Das ist dann das Wichtigste. Aber ist es nicht jetzt auch wichtig, möglichst schnell wieder Roller zu fahren? Also, dass sich da so keine Angst abzulegen entwickelt, so und zum Trauma? Ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht wie Fliegen oder so oder was auch immer, was mein Leben massiv einschränkt, wenn ich diese Roller nicht mehr benutze. Vielleicht lebe ich sogar länger, wenn ich diese Roller nicht mehr benutze. Du darfst sie jetzt nicht aufhalten lassen. Ich glaube, und da bin ich auch bereit, dir zu helfen, ruf mich gerne an jederzeit, dann komme ich bei dir vorbei. Mit was, mit dem Roller? Und dann stellen wir uns gemeinsam auf den Roller, ich unterstütze dich, ich gebe dir die Sicherheit, du bist noch nie so ein Roller gefahren. Ich glaube, du machst die Fahrt eher gefährlicher. Ich bin für dich da, Stefan. Du stehst hinter mir. Ich bin für dich da. Aber du stehst... Vorsicht! Nein, aber ich wäre für dich da, weil ich glaube, du musst möglichst schnell wieder ran, damit du jetzt keine Angst aufbaust. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, nur einen Flitzer. So ein unnötig Alert-Beifahrer finde ich lustig. Ja, ja. Vorsicht! Oh, hey, hey! Ja, chill, in fünf Minuten. Kurve einfach. Ja, oh, oh, oh, oh irgendwie Versteckte Kamera, Comedy Street und sowas echt fett. Ja, das ist vergangen, aber das heißt nicht, dass das nicht auch eine Zukunft hat. Wir hatten selber schon clevere Ideen für Versteckte Kamera, Ideen, die sich alle nicht durchgesetzt haben, weil Guido Kanz einfach nicht auf unsere E-Mails antwortet. Man kann aber auch sehr gut, und das ist vielleicht das Problem an E-Mails, man kann sehr gut auf E-Mails nicht antworten. Oh, schön. Man kann die so oft ignorieren und trotzdem hat man noch ein gutes Verhältnis mit dem, den man ignoriert hat. Das schafft dieses Medium sehr, sehr gut. Ich ghoste Leute
per E-Mail seit Jahren.
Ab und zu kommt immer noch eine Mail rein,
die einigermaßen nett formuliert ist.
Stichwort Spam-Ordner,
dann kommt dann so ein Spam-Ordner,
ist untergegangen, ja, bei mir geht es oft unter.
Mein E-Mail-Postfach
ist die Hölle auf Erden.
Tausend Spam-Nachrichten.
Meins gar nicht. Ich bin ganz offen. Wenn ich jemals gesagt habe, ist es untergegangen bei mir bei den Mails, Lüge. Bei mir geht keine Mail unter. Guck dir das mal an. Du bist nämlich einer von denen, die mir zugutekommen. Guck dir mal nur die Uhrzeiten an und es sind alle Spam-Nachrichten. Jesus fucking Christ. In der Minute, im Minutentakt. Ja, ich kriege im Minutentakt Spam-Mails. Und du hast allerdings auch so 10.000 Mails. Bei mir ist null ungelesen, wirklich. Nee, nee, nee, das habe ich schon lange aufgegeben. Aber deswegen glaube ich, dadurch, dass mein E-Mail-Post auch so eine Katastrophe ist, gehe ich davon aus, dass es bei allen anderen auch so ist. Dass meine Mail natürlich untergeht und dass es einfach völlig normal ist. Und Leute wie ich, die Leute anlügen, wenn sie sagen, es ist untergegangen, profitieren halt von Leuten wie dir, die ungepflegte... Und deswegen mache ich das auch. Ich meine, früher, als die Leute Brief geschrieben haben, es kann sein, dass sich der Postbote im Wald verirrt hat oder von einem Bär gefressen wurde oder so, du hattest keine Ahnung und da hast du dann auch nochmal irgendwie so, Hölderlin hat nochmal so, ähm, hallo, wollte nochmal nachfragen, ist der Brief angekommen oder alles okay bei dir? Nie wieder was von gehört, aber ist in Ordnung. Aber ich mag das. Nie wieder von der Person gehört.
Das ist diese Form der neuen Kommunikation durch technische Fortschritte, die es erlaubt, dass man durch, obwohl aggressives Ignorieren, immer noch ein Verhältnis miteinander hat. Ein gutes, rettbares Verhältnis. Ich meine, heute haben wir den Begriff ghosten, aber es muss doch im Zeitalter des Briefeschreibens auch schon einen Begriff gegeben haben für jemand antwortet nicht auf meine Briefe, oder? Ja, ignorieren. Ghosten finde ich auch streng genommen, finde ich das ein Anglizismus zu viel. Ich weiß, ha ha ha kommt von mir ausgerechnet, von Mr. Anglizismus. Aber das ist schon kein gutes Wort, was nicht viel mehr addet als jetzt das Wort ignorieren, oder?
Ja. Aber das ist schon kein gutes Wort, was nicht viel mehr addet als jetzt das Wort ignorieren, oder?
Ja, das stimmt schon. Es ist halt eine spezielle Unterart von Ignorieren.
Man weist sofort, dass es um technische Nachrichten ignorieren geht.
Aber das finde ich interessant, weil Dienste wie WhatsApp oder so machen es schwieriger, ein gutes Verhältnis zu jemandem zu haben und ihn zu ignorieren oder sie, weil WhatsApp oft anzeigt, gelesen oder diese Dienste angeben, gelesen oder zwei Haken heißen, es ist zumindest angekommen oder sowas. Anders als Mails, die untergehen können, können WhatsApps weniger gut untergehen, iMessage weniger gut untergehen und so. Jetzt ganz neu, habe ich gesehen, hat mir jemand geschrieben und ich hatte, weil ich zum Schlafen immer diese Mondtaste beim Apple reinmache, diese Nichtstören-Funktion, dann wurde die Person benachrichtigt, dass ich gerade auch nicht stören, was für diese Person, weil es das erste Mal war, aber so wirkt, als hätte ich sie blockiert.
Ah ja.
Stefan hat nicht stören.
Stefan möchte nicht von dir gestört werden.
Du bist eine Störung für Stefan.
Ich liebe das, wie so ein Butler aus so Filmen, wo so, Herr Tietz hat sich in den Westflügel zurückgezogen, er möchte gerade nicht gestört werden.
Wir haben ihn seit Tagen nicht gesehen.
Es gibt gar keinen Westflügel. Moment mal. Herr Tietze! Und er war nie wieder gesehen. Moment mal. Immer wenn Herr Tietze weg ist, kommt der Gummimann und löst alle Verbrechen der Stadt. Gummibaum, träumet Blätter hier und da. Er ist für dich da im Sommer und Frühling. Doch im Herbst ist das nicht. Doch im Herbst ist er einfach nur kalt. Super Song, Super Song. Gummibaum, das Musical ist schon quasi geschrieben. Die Blätter fallen quasi von selbst. Wir müssen sie nur noch auffangen. Wir müssen sie nur noch auffangen, helft uns doch dabei, helft mir dabei, dieses Problem zu lösen. Ich wünsche dir echt viel Erfolg, weil ich habe diesen Gummibaum auch ein bisschen in mein Herz eingeschlossen, muss ich sagen. Du hast ihn ganz einmal gesehen. Deswegen ist er auch Teil meines Lebens und es würde mich sehr, sehr schmerzen, wenn er tatsächlich von uns gehen würde. Deswegen macht den Gummiband-Effekt, haltet ihn in meinem Leben, zieht ihn zurück wieder hoch. Ja, du hast seltsam oft nachgefragt, wie es dem Gummibaum geht, dafür, dass du ihn nur einmal gesehen hast. Ja, ich freue mich ja auch. Vielleicht, also ich will nicht sagen, dass, also, ich habe jetzt ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil ich vielleicht auch Teil, also man kann nicht ausschliessen, dass ich Teil mitverantwortlich bin, dass es dem Gummibaum nicht so gut geht. Einmal nicht gesehen. Ja, aber vielleicht, also ich sag nur, wenn es in der Ermittlung rauskommt, dass ich vielleicht was damit zu tun hätte, dass der Gummibaum, dass da vielleicht irgendjemand irgendwas mal, also nicht im Sinne von, aber also. So oft nachgefragt. So. Ciao. Hast du einen rostigen Nagel in den Gummibaum geschlagen? Das habe ich auch immer gehört, dass das Bäume kaputt macht.
Funtin ist schon gegangen. Sorry.
Macht's gut. Eine ganz fantastische Woche.
Vielen Dank für Joseph und das wunderbare Intro.
Wir heben ab. Macht's gut.
Funtin, komm doch noch mal kurz zur Abendmoderation zurück.